every business i have five companies now
we'll do a hundred million this year i
started every one of those companies
with no money zero money man just hustle
and grit and courage
i've called on people i didn't want to
be with i've done things i didn't want
to do okay it is not about doing what
you love it's about doing whatever it
takes
to make your dreams a reality to be
closed and stay closed if you're not
closed on your product if you're not
buying your own product why would you
expect anybody else to
man 400 bucks is a lot of money your
prospect says to you 400
do it
listen to me man you're 32 years old
you've been trying to save money for 20
years and you hadn't do it and do it now
i don't need anything special here i'm
not going to be empathetic
quit being stupid right to check
i don't know if the compliance guy likes
that or not
but i know this look if you believe in
what you're selling how many of you
believe in what you're selling
then close the deal
then close the deal okay learn to close
and you'll never be without work you'll
never be without money you'll have an
organization that is booming in
affluence
you'll have a pipeline full you'll have
appointments filled up
right i call it a a group called me
yesterday i'm actually trying to do a
deal with cnbc and the guy says i'm
interested i said good i'll be there
tomorrow call me back i'll be i'm flying
into new york tomorrow what am i trying
to do right now by the way i was
supposed to be here today
i'll fly into new york tomorrow i can be
there tomorrow mr ackerman okay how does
that work i can't do tomorrow i was
going to be here anyway i'm trying to
close the day let me close the deal i'll
figure out how to be in two places at
one time later
right you some of you in the room
they're like hey i can see it four
o'clock on tuesday right and the
customer says to you i'll see you at 4
o'clock
let me look at my calendar like like
you're so busy
dude that is so old
that is so old and it's dishonest
[Music]
it's dishonest man
you want to see me tuesday four o'clock
i give you tuesday at four o'clock agree
today
done
done i'll call you if something changes
if there's an earthquake between now and
next tuesday tuesday morning there's a
massive earthquake and i can't be there
you think everybody will understand
commit first they're gonna rest out
later close the deal right now fill your
calendar up your calendar's got the
devil all over it
white space on a calendar and you will
meet the devil
you don't need to die okay you go two or
three days without anything going on how
many of you start having doubts
you're in hell
oh my god this ain't gonna work for me
there's nobody coming in i'm not gonna
hit my target okay i know what i'll do
i'll lower my target
that's the devil doing that man that's a
criminal
never ever if you're taking notes never
lower a target
never lower a target
never lower a target your mom and dad
would tell you to lower a target a
manager might tell you to lower target
be reasonable
[Music]
be reasonable with yourself
just bring it down a little bit no man
criminal products are created like that
a guy sees the girl that he wants that's
the girl
she says no he goes to another girl
right gave up on his dream if you're
going to give up in your own dream how
are you going to build an organization
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
grant cardone and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
[Music]
rule number two let go of things that
hinder you you will never
ever experience great change in your
life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life
i have had to give up something i wanted
so i'm not talking about getting rid of
the bad stuff you got to get rid of
something that you actually worked for
to get
it might have been the house
it might have been oh my kids are in the
best schools now it's going to be
something painful for you to get to the
next place you have to give up something
that you worked for really really hard
so i sold my house one day i had this
cognition hey to get what you want you
have to give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life i had to leave lake charles
louisiana went went to houston had to
leave houston once i got comfortable
with my community and my friends had to
leave san diego had to go to la la is a
pit
compared to la jolla nobody goes from la
jolla california up to los angeles
nobody does that
you'll leave kansas city to go to los
angeles
because you want to be an actor i met
elena within five minutes of arriving in
l.a
i sold my house i sold my house i didn't
leave it vacant
as a backup plan i left this house okay
like i couldn't buy this house today if
i wanted to it was so like it was a
precious little treasure
i had to give that up by the way i had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me it wasn't a
restaurant i couldn't walk into i could
always get a seat i could always get the
best seat i had it right in my hand this
is what i'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever is
the big influence that significant other
person in your life
that you're going to consult that
everybody's going to consult every one
of you are going to hey what do you
think should i
you better have that person on your side
in my case i was by myself
so my consultant was like you gonna do
this dog i called my buddy dale dale you
think i should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what do you have to risk
sold the house went to los angeles lived
in a hotel i went from a house on the
ocean to living in a hotel the hotel
room was probably like i don't know
maybe the size of this stage
so please please do whatever you got to
do this weekend to figure out whatever
you got to do to get rid of whatever is
holding you back most of which is
something you worked hard to get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got him already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it rule number three deal with life head
on people say the dumbest things it
could be family it could be your wife
your husband it could be a a mom a dad a
uncle an aunt it could be your kids
coming from school people say what they
think and what they think will be what
they say and what they say and think
often enough long enough reinforced
enough i promise you will be what they
do okay so look at some of the dumb
things you say like this here's one dumb
thing people say
time heals all things
really
you get a splinter in your foot and you
don't pull the splinter out you don't
look at it confront it and say i gotta
pull that little
booger out i gotta pull that little
splinter out if you just leave it there
you might get used to it yeah you'll get
used to it 30 years goes by you still
got a splinter in your foot who knows
that splinter gets into your bloodstream
goes to your heart spikes your heart
kills you time does not heal all things
folks you know what heals all things
taking a look at it having the courage
to look at it hey what happened to me
how did i screw up here what what hurt
or what pain or what happened that i had
a loss i see people go through life with
all these losses unwilling to look at
them all crippled by the time they get
older not old but they looking old
because they believe that time heals
look time heals when you confront it
when you look at it when you pull the
splinter out and take responsibility for
it don't believe everything you believe
you know what i'm saying cause some of
the ideas you got they just dumb
and dumb things will cause you to do
dumb things rule number four get real
financial education for me like i was
always scared of money you know and and
i was terrified of it so so like if you
look at still today like i look at the
bill of everything
it's a bill of everything
if something costs something i want to
know how much it was
and so like
how much is it like i'm going to ask
that question
whether whether it matters or not um it
doesn't matter where i get in my life i
don't think i'm ever going to be free of
how much was that how much is the dinner
how much how much was dinner how much
was the tip how much was the code how
much was the jacket what did you know me
me and elena like elena's like hey it's
gonna be fine man like look what look at
look
look at what you've done we cannot spend
this and i'm like how much was it
i want to know how much it was because
when i grew up do you had to know what
things cost
and so the point your question about
money is it's a terrifying thing because
it's the one thing in life
that
you know the nfl is not going to give me
the ball
and and i'm never going to get a chance
to golf i can't win in those
environments but with money
everybody gets money it's the one place
where everybody gets it and now what do
i do
and i could lose it now
so it's a terrifying concept like like
power
you know very few of us ever ever get
any kind of influence or power right
once you get it you're like hey what do
i do with this you know am i going to do
it am i going to do the right things
with it and so i think people withhold
themselves because they don't we're not
educated about money we don't know where
it comes from we have a lot of
misinformation about it our parents
terrified us
you know money doesn't grow in trees
uh save your money it'll save you all
these these these things our parents
told us because they were enamored
uh or are encumbered
with the same kind of liabilities around
money right i don't know how to get it
i don't know how to keep it
and
the third the worst part that we're all
at is i don't know how to invest it yeah
so what i'll do is i'll some people get
good at getting it
very few actually fewer people at
keeping it
but probably more than getting it
there's probably a big group in america
that have learned how to keep money
because they're afraid to lose it they
don't want to invest it they don't want
to use it they don't want to you know um
you know kanye talks about this how
white people how white people save all
their money and they just keep it they
just store it like i had an uncle he
buried everything he ever made he went
in the backyard wow
the other uncle was was uh he was he was
a guy that bought he he worked hard very
very frugal
italian descent
and he would uh buy real estate but it
was always buy low and sell high he
actually never sold anything but that
was the concept buy low buy the cheapest
lowest
get everything on a deal if there's food
stamps to be gotten you go get those
food stamps if there's a if there's a
government deal get it if it's section 8
and the government will pay you pay it
so both these guys different kind of
mentalities were extremely frugal
my other uncle was uh worked in a
refinery he basically saved all his
money paid everything off got out of
debt that was their lifestyle my dad
died when i was 10.
so he paid all his debt off had
everything paid and so that's all i had
right everybody around me was like get
money
keep it keep it don't use it you know
but but you should invest but nobody
ever learns that third one
and and so i think we're just a bunch of
people walking around terrified
of this
this apparent
apparency of it's scarce right
and it's not
and and you know it's not there's
nothing scarce about it also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video i've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five attract success
you know i'm always keeping it real with
you what has happened to our country
that we make our idols and our icons and
our heroes rappers and entertainers and
ball players and then we show disgust
for a businessman that can bank 50
million a year or 20 million a year what
is wrong look when a guy can go out and
make passive investments great decisions
execute show tremendous discipline okay
and disconcert between good investments
and bad investments and then make 20
million or 30 million bucks pay three or
four million dollars in taxes three or
four million dollars to his charities
his churches his community helps out
with groups of people
and and we have discontent for the
businessman that's out there year after
year
making great investments great decisions
showing leadership in the marketplace
look that marketplace out there that
economy is the most savage
most
difficult playing field in the world to
negotiate yet
who do we admire in our culture rock
stars look these guys got great skills
kid gets out of school makes 12 million
the first year and we make posters of
them and sweatshirts and you put their
kids in their jerseys what about the
business people that make our economy
work to pay the taxes that make the
schools work the churches work that make
the the fire department the police
department because they pay taxes
because they're out there making great
investments look admire business people
they're able to bank year after year
admire these people study them learn
from them don't be disgusted with them
and turn off anybody anybody that would
suggest to you that making money in this
country is wrong look don't envy
business people admire them emulate them
learn from them particularly these guys
are doing it year after year after year
not just on income but on wealth
development because that's where you
need to be that's where you need to be
thinking that's the economy you want to
create for yourself your family your
household and your future rule number
six create time don't manage it you know
this concept of time management has been
pushed off on me my entire life and i
have never ever agreed with it i'm like
why would i want to manage time
why would i what am i going to do how do
you manage time what do i do i like okay
i'm going to watch these seconds dude i
don't want to manage time i want to
produce i want to be highly productive i
want to squeeze time i literally want to
take time and i want to turn 60 minutes
into three hours of production that's
the different thing that you need today
not manage time now there are some
tricks when managing time if that's
where you want to come from like alan
greenspan alan greenspan and his
roommate in college his roommate's
father taught alan greenspan a little
trick that alan greenspan used his whole
life and it was to break up the day into
15 minute blocks
15 minutes i have something and then
fill up the next 15 minutes now the
reason alan did that and i like that
concept a lot is because he didn't what
white space on that calendar he knew
white space was a problem because
white space nothing in the 15 minutes is
a waste of time
see before you start thinking about just
managing time first i want you to do
this number one i want you to make a
list of things that you're doing every
day that is a waste of time that is the
way you create time not manage it
the first thing i want to do is look at
things that i'm doing that are wasteful
those two or three hours a day that are
wasteful moments things i'm doing on
facebook that just a waste of time or
maybe a game i'm playing that's a waste
of time or maybe
a newspaper i'm reading where i'm not
really learning anything i'm reading
about the the celebrities it's a waste
of time okay second thing i want you to
do is this i want you to then start
thinking about these 15-minute blocks
and filling that calendar up but the
third and most important thing i want
you to think about is how can you create
time
how can you literally take 24 hours and
and pack more into it so that you can
become more productive so that you can
use that urgency concept and really blow
up your your career blow up your life
make the most incredible life for your
family for you for the kids for your
wife or your husband and for your
clients so that you can take care of
yourself materially as well rule number
seven focus on discipline 12 years ago
we had done maybe i don't know 20
million dollars over the internet
we've done over a billion dollars in
sales over the internet in the last 12
years
okay
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
like you guys got to learn how to use
enthusiasm like when you use it use it
like the more you use the more you get
you're like i'ma save my energy now i
don't want to give him too big a hand
too early
it's really early today come on look man
when somebody's successful you ought to
throw down that's what i'm talking about
see
you guys you guys got it y'all got y'all
got to quit trying little tricks and
gimmicks like if you got to walk on fire
to get excited you are ramped up
like like if you can't at will whenever
you want to for any reason just get
excited
then you got a problem okay because in
real in the real world you can't you
can't be in the middle of a meeting and
i'm trying to get her to give me like a
hundred million dollars and i'm not i'm
feeling a little depressed or bad right
now or i got my attention on my kids and
and i'm like okay
[Music]
everybody's gonna be like nah we weren't
gonna give you 100 until you started
pumping your chest
right you can't say hang on a second man
i got to go into a state change
like that's not real you guys understand
you have to be able to that's a gimmick
and gimmicks take time okay and gimmicks
cannot be duplicated
what can be duplicated are disciplines
and that's what you're going to be we're
going to be sharing with you over the
next three days disciplines can be
duplicated if you've seen my children
okay if you've how many of you see
sabrina and scarlet
those are disciplines
okay
if they were in here right now they
could get on that stage and talk to you
they know how to look you and eyes they
know how to shake your hand because they
have been taught how to communicate
we spend less time on teaching them how
to count than we do communicate
connect with people okay we have them
home schooled the home school teacher
what do you want to learn you just keep
teaching them what i'm teaching them
you teach them confidence you teach
employees you teach them the ability to
communicate be dangerous not careful
okay we teach our kids how to be
dangerous
i teach my kids how to meet strangers
and greet strangers we teach our kids
that strangers have everything they want
and strangers are not dangerous
okay is there danger in the society yeah
that's what those guys are for over
there
so i'm gonna put my kids an environment
where they can meet 99 of the people and
feel safe to meet them talk to them
communicate with them so i want to make
sure that my kids can walk into an
environment and have
zero concern about him her or him
and they can walk out and say hey i want
to meet you because strangers
have everything that you want
the people you don't know and haven't
met these guys these guys dressed in
their robes what do you call the robes
the condor okay i have one in my closet
by the way i love the condor i put the
condor on one time and i was like i'm a
bad bad man
dude i felt so freaking powerful it was
amazing okay i grew a beard and i'm like
now i'm a man
okay give me a camel
okay it was like it was like phenomenal
right like but but you you guys need to
have that kind of swag everywhere in
life and regardless how old you are 25
and you're like i'm too young to have
swag or 55 and now you're too old it's
not true
you just need to get the confidence the
bravado not fake it you don't need to
fake it you need to you need to get you
need to get confidence if i could get
rid of this right here in life if i
could get rid of these downs man how
confident would i be
i mean like i'm going into every deal
i'm a win
and that is possible folks okay but it
starts with
who knows me
because if i'm walking around this
planet and nobody knows me i'm gonna be
terrified rule number eight be who you
are be a better guy man you know just be
a good guy and be b
you know the thing i'm proud of is i get
to be grant all the time you know i'm
actually getting to the point where i'm
like hey man i finally got to be when i
i finally
became what i wanted to be
what was that me yeah you know that i
don't have to apologize anymore and then
i quit screwing up and i quit having to
call people and say hey man like i said
i went too far you know if i could just
pull some of that back without that drug
that that psychiatrist was trying to use
right you know that if i'm less
dependent upon
aggression you know and i could i could
kind of manifest more
you know like you you talk about better
let it flow more let it flow dude let it
flow you know but but if i could get
that perfect balance of aggression and
flow
that's a sweet spot yeah it's sweet dude
it's hard to find that thing spot
you know to be that
i don't want to be i don't want to be
the little stream that drips you know i
want to be like
but i don't want to damage anybody right
i don't want to hurt anybody you know i
don't want to i don't want to be in
competition anymore mm-hmm but i also
don't want to lose the edge right you
know it's a dance dude it's a dance
match you know like like your girl said
to me the other night she's like she
said something before she left she's
like i really get who you are
you know that and that hits me when
people say that to me most people don't
get who i am um that's beautiful you
know and she said i really get who you
are yeah and and a lot of people don't
yeah and it sometimes it hurts right
because i know who i really am yeah
and
but i also know the things i'm trying to
accomplish for me you know like ryan
ryan gets who i am you know
ryan ryan never takes me on man you're
you're the best queen you're the best
he just he strokes me right right
through it and and and you know my wife
i can see my wife she gets she gets
tired of the the the pounding you know
but hey man i just you know i'm a
right-handed hitter you know or i got i
got a certain ball that i throw a
certain shot i make and yeah it's my
go-to you know and when i get threatened
i'm going to go to that
and now if i could develop some other
set of skills
you know that would be that would be a
cool thing rule number nine avoid
negative people the thing is not to just
be positive not even to offer this no
negativity policy that i talk about the
way to avoid
uh
negative and distracting people man is
to vibrate at a rate so fast okay that
you're out in front of them once i got a
speeding ticket actually here in miami
and the police officer says
why are you speeding why are you in such
a hurry i'm like dude i'm trying to stay
away from the crazies
okay
if i can just get ahead of everybody
else i'm not distracted by anybody but
guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and stop
my mission see so i got my ticket and
moved on and went to the head of the
pack again see this is what i'm telling
you man look if you want to not be
bogged down by negative distracted
people
you need to take responsibility that
you're slowing down enough to get caught
up by this magnetic charge of distracted
and negative people do you need to
vibrate so fast that these people are
distracting other people not you get way
ahead of the crowd get so busy that
nobody's gonna jack with you man because
you're filling up your pipeline you're
full you're busy and you don't have this
stuff sticking to you look if you got
negative people around you if you got
distracted people and we all do
but if it's causing you to be distracted
and negative dude you need to vibrate
you need to fill up your pipeline you
need to explode blow up get busy so this
isn't happening to you because you're
partly responsible fill your pipeline up
and rule number 10 the last one before
some very special bonus clips
is don't quit what are you willing to
give up you guys got to keep assessing
the situation and not be
not be
broad stroke about it and say oh i'm not
going to be a dilite or i'm going to be
a professional i'm going to i'm not
going to no no but what are you going to
give up
there are times though again when i will
give up
that
agreement see like one of the things i
have on here being right you have to
give up being right
you know you can't can't want to be be
right and be successful they don't even
go together
it's impossible so again i'm willing to
give the up being right just kind of
don't quit man if you don't quit if you
don't quit you can't fail
it's impossible failure becomes
impossible for those that don't quit
it's impossible just think about it if i
keep moving towards the destination
if i if i'm if i'm going through the
alphabet
a b c d e dude if you just keep going
all the way to z you finish the alphabet
you break your leg along the way
somebody cuts your tongue out you get
waterboarded you get a divorce you lose
your dad you lose a puppy
if you get the z you finish the alphabet
period and boy when i heard that i'm
like goddamn what was i thinking i was
thinking i could fail i can't fail if i
don't quit
so so that means i got to get rid i got
to dump people out of the car though
along the way right but we had to get
rid of a whole bunch of people
i i have to get rid of people how many
people have been have gone johnny
i mean guys like if you saw the wreckage
like
so much you don't see it you know oh i'm
not saying get rid of people i'm just
saying like like like what are you
willing to give up
okay on my list i've given up a house
i've given up money i gave up my
retirement accounts i had millions of
dollars sitting in retirement accounts i
paid the penalty to get the money
because it was a mistake years ago i got
convinced by the banks to build an ira
or a 401k because i was trying to figure
out how to exit actually the people that
were giving me the advice were telling
me to figure out how to exit
you're planning an exit when you're 30
and it's stupid
think about what you're doing you're not
going to retire until you're 70
and the rich people never
worry about their retirement accounts
warren buffett has not got a 401k
he's got coca-cola
see the difference
see the difference in the think
okay so so like like you you guys have
to take a look at what you know
that is now a liability
what you know to be true
that has become a liability for you
and if you just study the middle class
of america study the entire structure of
the american economy
you will see
you will see where a lot of these
liabilities exist that that are or are
core values that you have
not just for you but for the entire
population of people
and and like if you just look at the
structure of america 311 million people
most of them are not doing well
you hear about it every day so the
solution is let's give everybody college
you know
let's give everybody well college could
be one of the problems
look
you know let's make sure everybody gets
through high school okay could be one of
the problems actually that it takes 12
years to learn how to count
and still no product
really
so anyway i'm not saying i'm not worried
about trying to change all that i'm just
saying you might want to look at how
some of that has influenced you
you know the retirement accounts the
life insurance how many of you got life
insurance
how many of you got some cash value
sitting there somehow
dude get the money
don't wait till you die
how do you
build wealth
and stay happy at the same time
well number one is i don't think you
know
money will not make you happy like if
you're not happy you're not happy so
it'll make you jubilant and it'll make
you giddy for a second you know if i
dropped off 100 million
you know at your feet right now uh it
would definitely change your attitude
for a bit
but sooner or later you're coming back
you're coming back to your your your
happiness level
i've never tried to get money to make me
happy ever i have never thought oh i'm
gonna go get x money this much money and
i'm gonna somehow be happier i've never
ever
i don't even know where this concept
came from
the connection between the two
you know i go to the gym i think i'm
gonna build muscle
i go to the water fountain i think i'm
gonna quench a thirst
i go to a football game i think i'm
gonna be entertained
i get money i never think about okay i'm
gonna get 10 million bucks
and i'm gonna suddenly be happy
now i never i never even think about it
like that i'm gonna get 10 million
and then i'm gonna invest it and i'm
gonna pick up 30 million on the next
swing and i'm gonna take 30 million and
convert that to 90 million i'm going to
take that and convert it into 270 and
i'm going to get to you know blah blah
blah right and then what am i going to
do with it but
dude
i'm never thinking about it it's going
to make me happy best advice i ever
received my mom said hey invest in
yourself you'll never lose i have
reminded myself of that
so many times workshops i go to uh
events that i attend where i'm going as
somebody to get educated okay books that
i've read i'm like it's not a waste of
time
even even if you don't think you learn
anything it is not a waste of time you
think you think you haven't
that it was a waste of time or you
didn't learn anything because you hadn't
used it yet
you may use that piece of data one day
and so number one anything you invest in
time or or
or money and trying to improve yourself
you're not going to lose that the beauty
salon the restaurant the bar the bar
owner
the consultant we've all had the
experience of
resenting our customers starting not to
like them
and it's because we become dependent
upon them
we have too few if we're resenting our
customer what is that saying about us
that we're not building our brand that
we're not growing that we're not selling
enough yeah you didn't go you didn't you
didn't build the top of your funnel out
enough
because this this part of it's easy
even though you hate them they never pay
you money this is the kind of stuff that
goes on they don't pay me enough they
always complain they never use the
product no matter what i do for them
they [ __ ] and complain okay they're
never happy blah blah blah right
well the truth is those are indications
that you didn't build your your customer
base wide enough
because you now resent them your
resentment is an indication that you
rely on them too much
and every time they complain to you it
reminds you that i'm too reliant on too
little and and we've all done it we all
do it i've done it uh right now i'm
doing it in my real estate i told my guy
ryan the other day i said we're
depending on this one guy too much
and he's like why do you say that
because i'm starting to resent him
so what's the first thing we should do
what are those what's the action steps
after that when we resent our customers
you got it you got you got to understand
it's not about them it's about you
it has nothing to do with them you need
to go wide you need to go get more
customers
if you resent facebook if you if if
facebook pisses you off
it is because you are too
reliant on face the book it's money's
pretty simple too how do you get it how
do you keep it how do you multiply it
most people most people spend their
whole life just getting it they never
know how to keep it
um
i mean we don't even understand basic
stuff that currency is basically
uh comes from the word current where
something is moving you don't actually
get to
have own money you don't own the money
the money is going to go some other
place
and um so yeah it's unfortunate but
we're taught nothing on that subject how
do you maintain a positive
opportunistic upbeat attitude during
times like this
you know i look i struggle with it just
like everybody else this is not an easy
time it's scary uncertainties everywhere
bad news everywhere uh the thing the
thing that i continue to do is
i was just telling jared a few minutes
ago we're just thinking too small
you know let's let's we're thinking too
small
and so like i'm like where am i going
where am i trying to get to
uh because i could be seduced into a
beach right now pretty easily
i'm gonna go lay on the beach
and i don't need to do all this
you know and then i'm like wait a minute
there's no beaches open either like
there's the caribbean shut down the damn
st bart's is shut down there's uh
everywhere you go there's problems right
so there's no getting away from that
where am i going yeah
so so i the thing i need to wake up
every morning hey i'm still going for 10
billion worth of real estate maybe 20
yeah
why not 30.
so how do i do that got to stay relevant
got to keep paying my bills got to take
care of my properties got to show people
that i know how to get through tough
you can't expand if you if you fold
every hand you can't win if you fold
every hand
so you got to play the cards you got
right now it's tough
and then but i have to keep making
contacts with people that can actually
benefit me in 21 22 23.
i got i got to be i got to be a beacon
of possibility and potential and future
uh so so that when we go when things
start lifting off and we can do deals
um
i'm relevant to the conversation and i
got to cross my fingers dude and just
believe that
i got to believe that things are going
to get better you take care of yourself
every day you got to do the work some
things you cannot delegate
taking care of your body food you eat
somebody can cook it for you you still
got to put it in
and then you got to take care of
yourself
and then you got to take your ideas and
your dreams
only you know what they really are and
only you and you alone
know what your real potential is
your wife can't do that for you your
husband can't your boss can't your
manager can't
god's not gonna even do it for you folks
you to do that you want to be in good
shape you can pray for all you want
you want to get your money right you can
pray for it but you got to do the work
your destiny is waiting for you
but you got to do the work what's your
biggest um tip for anyone who
you know they obviously have all
intention purposes to to want to
collaborate what are some of the
the the best ins or the best ways around
money money of course pay money pay the
price money works yeah pay to play yep
universal language planet earth pay to
play
you know
whatever people i was doing before our
last conference and maybe we wrapping up
with this
before our last conference a guy came in
my office from a big bank and said hey i
want to uh i want to talk to you about
lending you some money for multi for
your apartment building so i'm like
great
have you bought a ticket to my
conference
no i haven't i said i don't have time
for you
so it's like pay to play man it is the
simplest hack on planet earth i'm gonna
take garbage pieces of paper
dumb little pieces of rectangle paper
and give them to you to speed up my
process i don't know why i don't know
why i didn't know this for 45 years yeah
and and i don't know why i was so hung
up
on trading paper for access
it's what all the big players do yeah
i mean i even had this arrogant thing
i'm not paying i'm not paying to connect
up like
dude this is how everything works on
this planet rule number eight get big
every city i've ever been to
when i work with ceos they say number
one problem here is the people
i said then you need to get better
so to the degree that you're having
problems with people you got to get
better and it starts with you
and you're only going to hire the people
like we we have people come to us i'm
turning resumes down i'm like i can't
see enough people like i got people that
too so so many people want to work with
us because we're successful right
and if you want good people
get big yeah everybody wants to work at
facebook okay the average person at
facebook makes 250 just under 250 a year
which by the way if you do any kind of
financial literacy you would know that
guy walks away with 60 grand
250 in silicon valley converts to 60 000
bucks after all his expenses he's broke
he might not have 60 by the way
so um
you know just you're going to have to go
through a bunch of people recruiting
should be the number one thing for every
company out there every entrepreneur
first thing you should look for is not a
sale that's what i did wrong i was
looking for a sale i should have been
looking for a recruit um
so focus more on team building than just
sales sales sales now now well you need
to recruit recruit recruit recruit and
that means you need to pay people now
we're back to that other ugly problem
that nobody wants to talk about i need
some money everybody wants to be the
boss
nobody wants to pay the invoice success
is a contact sport
you cannot be successful if you don't
make contact
you guys interview people and then you
never follow anybody up man nobody
follows anybody up
i spent i spent two million dollars with
a lawyer that's never called me back
same thing for the bar birth same thing
for the cosmetologist same thing for the
plumber same thing for the roofer dude
you guys don't call people back because
you think they're not interested do you
think i'm only going to have one car
accident people that have one car
accident end up in three of them
okay divorcees
guy gets a divorce everybody here knows
somebody's got four of them
but he ends up with four different
attorneys
like you guys don't follow up you are a
business not a lawyer
the chiropractor has the same problem he
goes and spends all this money on
equipment he knows how to do an
adjustment he doesn't know how to build
a business do you think from a marriage
perspective or from a partner
perspective where you've got this hunger
to go and build a business because i i
speak from my own experience here in the
sense of
if i'm not in a good space with my wife
or we might argue or something's not
right i couldn't give a [ __ ] about
building yeah yeah big business right
like that i agree with that i agree with
that
what advice do you have
if i didn't care i mean if my marriage
was falling apart right now
i would still care about my business
because my business is like my business
like my my dreams
are
so native to me
meaning they're innate they're that they
were with me before the kids and before
her
i'm not giving those up
and that's all i told her when i got
married to her i said look i i will give
anything up but i will not give those up
she's like i don't want you to i want i
want to see if i can make them bigger
i'm like now
you're my girl
so so that's what i want like i don't
want to give up and i don't want her to
give up on her dreams
right and then if the two dreams can
come together right
yeah and then and then the marriage is
going to be cool there's going to be
bumpy spots and working all that out and
who's doing what and you said this and
we correct each other all the time and i
wish you wouldn't have said that and
whatever you know i got a big mouth
um
but you know i think the spiritual
condition it should be first
and and and then that'll that'll handle
the marriage thing because for me my
dreams are a spiritual condition they're
like the things i want to do the things
i've always dreamed of the things that
satisfy me and make me feel with filled
like of a spiritual nature it's not
really about money for me i respect a
hundred dollars
so if you give me a hundred dollars
you know i respect that as a lot of
money
now that being said it's not gonna be a
lot for very long and if you got two
kids that need to eat today it depends
on what your needs are right i got a
wife and two kids so
i mean a hundred dollars probably gonna
last the whole day
uh but a hundred dollars for a minute
that's a lot of money now if i could if
i could figure out how to get more money
coming in the
it's only a lot of money if you got more
money coming in i understand because i
can all i can probably exhaust almost
any amount of money
this is this is the problem with the the
nfl the nba
the mlb the the the rappers when they
move on they got a pile of money but
what they don't have is
more money coming in gotcha and and so
now you know a million dollars is a lot
of money if you got
a thousand dollars every day coming in
because you can't get through it i
always tell elena i said dude as long as
we make a dollar more
because of my net worth if i make a
dollar just one dollar every day
i mean one dollar today is a lot of
money because it me it means i never go
backwards no one thing
no one thing will blow a good
relationship there's not one thing i can
tell my wife my wife says hey you're
getting fat
okay
what is that how's that gonna hurt me
y'all gotta get hard man y'all to
practice being hard y'all got to
practice telling people the truth you
all got to practice being hard on
yourselves you got to practice maybe not
taking every weekend off
okay i had a bunch of people leave my
office the other night at six o'clock
dave robarts is walking out of here all
these guys walking out at 603 natasha's
leaving at 6 00. i'm like oh you guys
are all rich now huh why do you think
you got to leave why do you guys think
you've earned the right to leave at six
o'clock
right why do you guys think you've
earned the right to charge over time for
everything that you do over time
well i need to get my overtime no you
don't you need to add value is what you
need to do you need to get hard on
yourself i have belief now i know i know
what i can do now once you know what you
can do then you can do it a second time
and that's why so many people can go
bankrupt and then come come right back
because they know now
the first time you do it you don't know
the second time you do it you're like i
think maybe the third and fourth time
you're like i know for sure i could do
this before you diversify go go bang on
another door yeah you need to become the
freaking doorbanging
of the universe so i want to talk about
that right because can i use that word
here
you need to become like you need to go
bang
yeah you need to go bang on the door
they tell you to get out of the
neighborhood and you go figure out how
to bang on it again and not get arrested
yeah
like if you can figure that gig out i
guarantee you you will be the most
successful person your genetic code has
ever generated yeah anyone in your
family everybody i know says man
learn how to cold call i i have the
career i have today because i'm because
i learned how to cold so if you took
everything away from me right now
the things that are most valuable to me
you can't take away
so you take the plane away you take the
money away
take the real estate poor the portfolio
away
three years from now i'll be bigger than
i was
because now i have courage
if you guys can just find your courage
man
and that that's a muscle you got to go
build a muscle of courage i have courage
nobody can take that away from you can't
steal it from me can't beat it out of me
what were the lessons you learned uh you
know starting from essentially zero
having no money no context
no uh relationships no
opportunities in
a town that you went to for this show
what did you realize
were the keys to actually making money
even if you didn't have any well as you
see the show you see that i actually
never make any money right so
uh the two girls they they actually
they follow three of us and the two
girls went out and got a job in the
first week
and
and i'm not saying that's right or wrong
or my way is more better or worse
but but they are strategies okay they're
different strategies i was not there to
get a job or to earn money
i was there looking for one thing
opportunity i never spent time looking
for money ever the entire
uh 90 days okay i'm not looking for
money i was actually looking for
contracts through the contacts
i wasn't looking for money because i
knew the evaluation of the company in
the last um
segment
an evaluator will come in and determine
what my company's worth my new company
right that i created
and at that point i just need to
validate to him
dude my company's worth this based on
that the entire 90 days i never touched
the first hundred they gave me and this
was to prove to people do you do not
need money like it's just it's not true
you need money you do need contacts
you need people you need people you need
people you need the right people though
the right people that are already in
play
okay just because the guy's got money
i remember a a billionaire friend of
mine uh you know he could buy a jet
and i said hey bob should i buy a jet he
said you should i shouldn't
meaning grant should because and he's
way wealthier than i am he could have
bought 40 of them he's like i don't have
a place to go in mine you have a you can
use yours every day
so you've got to find somebody that's in
place somebody that not just has money
but somebody that wants to do more with
their money
so you'll notice in the first uh 10 days
i don't spend a hun any money i don't
spend money on shelter not on food and
not on water
nothing then what i do is i end up
accumulating assets and it's unfortunate
that the viewer doesn't see this within
five days i have two vehicles one was
given to me by discovery and the other
one was a forty thousand dollar jeep
that i basically used
uh from ryan this guy i met
and told him i'm gonna sell your jeep
i'm gonna drive it around town and put
10 miles a day on it and i'm gonna sell
it well that's a forty three thousand
dollar asset
uh my truck was worth four grand i still
had my hundred dollars i lived in a
forty six thousand dollar rv
that i was trying to sell so yeah
and then what what's the other thing i
did and i picked up ten thousand dollars
to do in a 15 partnership in the equity
of the upside of this guy's company so
literally in 10 days
i was accumulating contacts that could
get me equity and the important part of
that story is man go get you some equity
you know jay-z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
i'm picking up the equity when uh kovit
happened in the country shut down
i flew in i told i told my guys i'm like
hey guys i want to get rid of an entire
department 43 people and they're like
you're overreacting i said good sleep on
it we'll talk tomorrow okay so that next
morning i called him at eight o'clock
i'm like are you guys ready to let
kill the department no we're not i said
well good kill the department it's not
your call it's my call wow i don't need
your support on it eliminate the
department there was two reasons i did
that number one i needed i needed our
attention by the way it is the dream
department of this company i've tried to
put this department together for seven
years and failed
and i'm still gonna do it it's a big
dream of mine so i had to give up a
dream of mine now this is this is one of
my principles of success
dude if you want to move give up
something
give something up surrender something
you love like
43 people did lose their job okay it's
terrible 40 million would lose their job
in the next four months
my 43 were the first
i was probably the first person to let
people go in america one of the things i
built my entire career over one thing
that probably has me responsible for
more deals more closes more companies
more business than any other single
thing i've done in my career
write the deal up okay when i'm buying
real estate i've bought and sold 750
million dollars worth of real estate
every one of them every property i
bought was a sales game it was all a
sales game first i had to get my
finances right second thing i had to do
was make a call follow the guy up he's
trying to sell a property i gotta find
out why would you sell it to me how can
i get in his circle of influence okay
how can i get their attention how can i
then follow them up to keep their
attention every real estate deal i've
ever bought
required me to follow up just to buy the
deal which is a sales job three i had to
use my mixed
pass to get the deal for i had to write
a deal up i can talk till i'm blue in
the face
there's a there's a guy i wanted to buy
his property he wouldn't respond to my
phone call so what i did was send him an
loi a letter of intent to purchase his
property number four if you don't get to
the write-up nothing matters you guys in
retail you guys and gals in retail if
you're not writing the customer up
you're showing the product presenting
the product walking around the product
and you never write them up you will
never close the deal every deal you have
ever closed in your entire lifetime
guarantee you wrote it up
you didn't talk about it to close it you
had them on a contract on a proposal
somebody had to sign something to buy it
you wrote them up
i was married to my business
i was not going to do this until i had
money
was that a good decision
one thousand percent or like if would if
you had a relationship you're not
accelerating no no no no
explain that because i was the dream and
i believe this i told my wife when i got
with her i said look i'll do anything
for you except one thing
i will not give up on that dream
if i got to surrender my dream i'd
rather be alone
because if i abandon my dream i'll
abandon you i truly believe that i see
so many people man they give up their
dream for the wife they give up their
dream for the husband they give up their
and then and then the wife and the
husband get together and they have kids
and then they give up their dream again
because of the kids
and i said the day we have kids we
cannot blame the kids for not going
after our potential and our dreams if we
ever have kids when we were getting
together
and she wasn't ready to have kids she
wasn't even ready for me
and and so i knew she was the right
person for me and i'm like look i'll
give you anything monogamy i'll never
cheat on you i'll never jack around on
you i'll take care of you i'll provide
you with a life that you can only dream
of
this was 12 years ago i mean this is way
before grant really hit full grant and
which she's really um
added to
and made it easier but um
i said look if you if i got to be less
than who i'm meant to be to be with you
that's powerful can't give you that
that's strong so i said i got books in
me this was before i'd ever written a
book i said i got books in me i'm gonna
do the biggest events in the world i'm
gonna do a tv show okay i will i will be
known by millions if not billions of
people
and i will leave a legacy
and and and that
that has been with me before i ever met
you
amazing and i'm not giving that up
because if i give that up i'll give you
up i mean different people have
different ways they invest but they tend
to be more
focused on the long-term appreciation of
an asset
rather than give me money this second
and and i think they get they're they're
not stuck in this get rich quick thing
it's a delayed gratification yeah
they're more like yeah i'd rather have
wealth tomorrow than rich today
and they do have a distinction between
the rich and the wealthy the you know
the super wealthy are looking to create
wealth beyond
their own
means and needs like they're not
thinking about their kids their boat
their plane i know people think that but
that's not actually true they're
actually thinking about how do i create
wealth for a lot of people amazon's got
a million employees
yeah now most of them only earn minimum
wage but there's some people at the
upper level of amazon that are making
fortunes
training
if you're not going to train then put a
sign on your desk i quit learning a long
time ago and see how many people want to
buy from you
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids i quit learning i
quit reading i quit studying i quit
training i can't get any better
put on there done i'm finished i'm in
retirement early i'm going to purgatory
i'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers and hope they bring me to sales
heaven
look you're done if you don't train okay
now i know you know this you've heard it
i hate to tell you this
my boy mcgregor connor
conor mcgregor or mcgregor my boy conor
mcgregor okay i went and saw him fight
in new york i went and saw him fight for
one reason because i saw him say
i'm not the best this isn't about talent
it's cause i'm obsessed i out train
everyone else i have to win so bad i
train
look if you're not training that says
something about your obsession or lack
of obsession
with winning i want you to win
i know your your wife or your husband
your spouse your family members your
kids your mom and dad want you to win at
the next level no matter what they tell
you
even if they tell you you're doing great
pat you in the back you know the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win is to
read the only way to win is to learn
learn more listen more
learn something new look we're in a
we're in a time like we've never been
before
technology's come and go faster than
people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or or short videos or videos
that disappear or videos that say or
text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which i've been
using a lot
look the world's changing and if you're
saying to yourself i'm too old to learn
that well then guess what you're too old
to learn that if you can't learn
anything new just put i'm ripe and i'm
about to fall off the tree and nobody's
going to want me look man you got to
train every single day like your life
depends on it
train every single day i am here today
i own these four companies that i own
the studio my reputation everything is
because when i was 25 years old to when
i was 30 years old every single day
i trained watching video every day i'd
watch the video i'd walk in and then i
would role play and then we would do a
sales meeting every single day
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there